he made it wrong like Bob shabbop
grinding my beans are wrong
you use the same thing to make all the
four shots
[Music]
did we start
hello
check chess
uh it's not chess it's thirst
what's really bad I'll be honest what's
really bad is these two are both here
why is that really bad it's just so much
like up upper stuff oh sugar so much
sugar and coffee just like
not the best thing for you at least in
the amounts I drink it in mm-hmm it's
like ridiculous what you drink a lot of
coffee I do I used to drink a lot more
coffee no when I drink I drink magic
mine with my coffee oh wow okay it helps
you focus all day oh okay and that's the
truth I feel upbeat and good so that's
what magic mind does and I'm just saying
it just to say it I don't even have a
deal with them or anything I'm just
saying it
hey it sounds like a video within B it
sounds like you're being stern about it
like you're angry you'll drink it
um
but I will say this
you haven't
you wanna what you've obviously noticed
something what about your what about
your appearance did you want me to
notice that I didn't notice your watch
you've obviously noticed something about
me no
um I mean if it's a tattoo I don't know
because you have so many I can't keep
track two I do have many okay okay
I'm a little bit more fit oh you're
beefier yeah actually yeah honestly you
actually are oh nice I did not expect
that to go that way yeah but I'm not I
don't I don't like it was they say on
you stay in your withhold when it's not
true I'm just telling the truth and it
happens to be in the case with you that
it is often negative
he's beefier you know why I do crazy
back work I do crazy shoulder work and I
do deadlift City and it's always leg day
I'll tell you that much you know it's
always been interesting about you and
our Dynamic you've never stopped talking
about working out since you began
working out I was still in high school
you've done it all throughout our
relationship you talk about working out
not after Instagram became a thing you'd
send me workout videos all the time for
gym accounts buff dude accounts yeah
trainer accounts I send you every single
time yeah I say I don't want to see that
I don't care I don't and I don't work
out right I don't care about people who
work out I don't care about the accounts
that show videos of people working out
whether it's a lot of weight whether
it's a little bit of weight whether they
fall whether they trip whether something
falls on their head I don't like it I
don't care okay and so let's fall down
you don't care let's ask you no I mean
if they fall down I'll give it to you so
what's going on why do you still why do
you still because I care about it and my
passion is something that is that that
is something you appreciate but I don't
send you baseball stats well baseball
players I do sometimes I jokingly say
so-and-so did this on my fantasy team
and you jokingly say you care but that's
like a thing we do yeah I don't expect
you to care but what about how when I
send you video of weightlifting guys
what do you think I'm thinking
when you send them to me or when you see
them when I send them to you what do you
think I'm thinking
um maybe you're Maybe by now you're
thinking
this is funny that it's an established
thing that pisses Matt off no uh I am
showing you
stuff that is amazing and it's hilarious
that now you have to see it because I
sent it to you well okay that I wouldn't
have even guessed that is rude though
but well we can get into this a little
bit later but uh I will be in Las Vegas
and Charlotte and uh Cleveland and
Knoxville and Little Rock and Nashville
Calgary Alberta a bunch of Canadian
dates crystalia.com so go over there and
get your tickets here's another thing
too I want to talk about we have patreon
here at Lifeline luxury and there is
another episode of Lifeline luxury on
um if you go on patreon.com Lifeline
luxury where it's just me and you
bantering back and forth it is the
hottest patreon on the planet and it's
really fun and funny and it's me and you
and it's uh at least two episodes extra
a month I think we did three last time
uh anyway there's one out now uh and go
get Lifeline luxury and uh see what
they're backlogged see what the episodes
are there already
um so yeah so there's that you'll enjoy
it yeah you will guarantee it um you can
go to watch lifeline.com if you've got a
video you want to send in and submit by
the way we only do that here on Lifeline
not live
just Matt and I bullshitting and uh
that's a very special show
um one-on-one advice sessions if you'd
like to talk to Matt mattelia.com and
last but not least we have the most
beautiful merch in the world
lifelinemerch.com and we got the purple
with the Peppa Pig I think a lot of this
stuff sold out but go go check go peruse
you know what I mean yeah take a gander
know what I've had stuck in my head a
lot but got into Cleveland late last
evening oh yeah you know what that is of
course I do Tupac thing because I'm
gonna be in Cleveland I thought about
how I'm going to be in Cleveland
performing and then I thought about that
every time I think of Cleveland I think
of a gun in Cleveland last evening okay
that's a bone doctor's Harmony song with
Tupac yes it is now
what my thing it's when you say
Charlotte Charlotte Charlotte yeah I
every time you start saying that word it
sounds like and because technically
everyone's who says it makes it sound
like this but I never thought about
until you say it and every time you say
it I think it okay which is it sounds
like you're gonna say charlatan but you
stop after the T Charlotte
well that's just because charlatan is no
longer word than Charlotte I know but
I'm saying the only you always think of
charlatan when I say Charlotte and no
one else not not anyone else I mean no
not that many people say Charlotte to me
you know what I mean but I've heard it
hundreds of times in my life well you
think people in Charlotte think that
I'll be in Charlotte soon
uh I bet people are Charlotte are so
used to it that they don't even uh
you know Carlton think about it
um yeah so I don't know I think that
that's pretty crazy you know what I mean
so something else is something's going
on here where Anthony
uh showed us he thought it was
interesting and I don't I needed I need
it explained because that's when you
look at the picture I know nobody has
any context yet yeah but the headline is
would you buy this microscopic handbag
someone just did for 63 750 now there's
a photo yeah and on the photo sure could
be in fact an extreme close-up of a of
the tip of a finger and on the tip of a
finger yeah tiny like like the kids and
Honey I Shrunk the Kids is what I
presume to be a purse is that right
looks like a piece of glass but I don't
know either way Anthony can keep his
penis in it right I think it's like a
holster for it's the same guy that made
the red boots that everyone was wearing
from oh what yeah that's it so that's
what it looks like huh yeah that's all
all they could just take a picture of a
big one and say that's what that is
honestly they could because yeah for
sure now what I want to know is why
anyone right would buy that well you
can't even put anything in
hold on dude I gotta bring my atoms
yeah it's it's they're molecule dude
gotta bring my molecules hold up [__] I
forgot my molecules at the restroom we
gotta go back you could fit three
even at that you can fit about a handful
of molecules in there and molecules are
literally so small you can't see them
scientists so this purse can pack about
five to ten molecules yeah what'd I say
purse isn't that a purse yeah but it's a
handbag to be more specific okay so this
handbag contain Louboutin it's not a
Louis Vuitton it's a guy doing a Louis
Vuitton bag right right Louis Vuitton by
this guy dude why would you buy why
would you buy it for 63 000 to say I
have the smallest handbag You're Gonna
Lose I'm gonna lose it I have it too
look it's in here it's in here so anyway
I got that no but for real though if you
buy that
it doesn't matter if it's like on a lark
you think it's funny whatever you are a
huge huge prick your piece you're such a
prick and here's why that money could do
a lot of things and I I don't like it
when people like oh you could have given
that to charity because sometimes it's
like under somebody wants to do a thing
that's really expensive
the right to do it whatever this is no
one deserves this no one should want
this it serves no utility obviously yeah
but it also isn't even like
a status thing no one can see it right
really you don't buy things no one can
see yeah it's even if you're a shallow
[__] yeah you know what I'm saying
it's basically you know like uh what's
his name Jeff Bezos has a 500 million
dollar yacht
that that's you know at least you can
use it that's what I'm yeah I mean
that's terrible it's truly nuts and
truly nuts and terrible wasteful save
lives yes many but I you know what do
you think about that dude you think you
should I don't know here's what I think
about that as the wealth Gap not to be a
nerd but because the wealth Gap grows so
big
and the money is concentrated in so so
many fewer fewer people yeah it's like
it's it's it's inhuman to to collect
that much money right because no one can
right rightly say I earned it like right
it's not the system is set up for people
who have more to continue to get more
right you didn't earn it that is a
literal principle of physics so what so
what uh what do you think that you I I
would say a high percentage of very very
wealthy men are like sociopaths you know
what I mean and oh yeah because of that
that's why they're so successful people
miss the point when they say how much
money do you really need that is not the
point yeah yeah it's not it's totally
different and I'm not defending it but
you're missing the point if it if you
think it's about the actual money
literally it's not about that it turns
into a different thing for people who
are that rich yeah and they're playing a
different game yeah and that's like a
whole part of it to them you know like
Jeff pesos wants to be richer than yeah
angle too it becomes a competition with
a small group at the top Yeah but
I don't care about any of that 500
million yacht as you said at least you
can be on it right right right on the
ocean right something so yeah it is at
least this is true nothing yeah so you
would nothing so you don't be funny is
if if you cut it in half and sold each
piece for twenty five thousand dollars
or whatever thirty thousand dollars yeah
yeah I mean that that would actually be
great because you would expose it for
the ludicrous thing that it is and
that's what that's what it is then
that's what yeah you cut it in fourths
and try to upsell it be like 20 grand
for each yeah yeah right yeah and then
you make some money on that [__] or
maybe it's something that's gonna
appreciate in value somebody buying that
to to like as a as an asset like this is
going to get way more way way more
valuable as time passes yeah just have
it like this and there it is how about
we're over great
I mean that's so true dude yeah so I
would drop it immediately you know we
could never hold it Kristen you know who
she'll never hold it me no Kristen will
just it would just go
dude she'd put it down no she'd put it
down and walk away and I'd be like
where's the handbag the mini handbag and
she'd be like
I give it to you right and I'd be like
it's over it's gone you owe me 63 G's
imagine trying to get insurance on it
like nothing applies to this thing yeah
and there's a reason for that yeah
because it doesn't fit in the system
isn't the reason it's good things that
fit in the system are bad this is worse
than things that do fit in this this is
like the shittiest Apex shittiness Peck
shittiness you know yep I think that's a
cool name for a movie Apex shittiness
yeah yeah saw Tulsa King
that is not worth
applauding isn't that a Terence winter
show who's that maybe yes it is right
yeah who's that he okay every major show
that is truly legendary and great
there's the person who created it and
the reason it is a great show is because
of obviously the person who created it
but there's also someone yeah that picks
up the Reigns throughout the course of
the show that makes it maintain its
thing because you can't be the same
thing for three four five six years so
someone that's him it's like a magic
potion that sometimes happens on some
shows that's him on The Sopranos yeah he
did that on The Sopranos with David
Chase or whatever David Chase created it
then him and Matt Weiner took over the
Reigns and made Sopranos the greatest
thing ever and he went on to do
Boardwalk Empire Mount weiner obviously
did Mad Men but that's like the most
boring as [__] yeah
yeah so boring right so actually he was
the only guy throughout the whole run of
the show and I think a lot of people's
complain about Mad Men was that it got
like I actually thought it got better
the first couple seasons are to me super
boring yeah
but I remember season four season five
really good well I saw Tulsa King and
it was phenomenal dude oh okay have you
seen it no seen it
so annoying dude wow
honestly I really like Sylvester
Stallone best he's been in so long
okay
when was he this good or is it the best
he's ever been
I mean I don't know he's not like known
as an actor no but he he's a really good
star so fast instead of it I know I know
I know well he does that action [__] you
know which is whatever Expendables I
mean how do you act in that it's
whatever it is but um I think it's the
best things driven no I'm kidding um I
don't even know what that is driven with
Kip Pardue or whatever the [__]
um wow I don't even know what that is
yeah yeah
um no but uh it's he's so good it's so
good the tone is so good and it's just
so great and it's on Paramount plus and
there we go is it like a gangster show
it's like a guy who for those of you
that don't know it it's a guy who
uh goes to jail for 25 years for and he
doesn't snitch so he takes the rap goes
to jail he did kill somebody but he goes
to jail gets out comes back to the
family and he expects them to like I'll
have him with open arms and they're like
we got nothing for you here but we want
you to start uh uh the our branch in
Tulsa and he's like those what the [__]
I'm from New York right yeah and then
they're like oh [__] well you're gonna
be in Tulsa and he gets really pissed
off and then he starts saying he starts
earning in Tulsa and he butts up against
this biker gang and this biker gang
wants him out and then also you find out
that the family just put him out there
to like basically an exile yeah because
they didn't know what to do with them
and [__] he's earning yeah he's starting
to make a lot of money and then he's
like I'm making a lot of money why the
[__] you might give it into that man you
know
I don't know why that's so [__] crazy
dude because he's so good in it though
he's just like anyway well we got this
bike again you know hey
but he's good as [__] it dude
Stallone is so good if he wants to be I
did some green yeah bro you know what I
mean yeah why don't you tell him we're
in a bowling league yeah like what like
Copland you think he's getting Copland
that's Niche Niche for me was Stallone
Stallone should be a big strong guy who
like muscles his way around he should be
that when he plays like a lunking like
dummy it doesn't work
for me anyway he's good at it he's
definitely a legend though I mean he's
yeah he is pretty amazing yeah a
cliffhanger yeah that's some that's
that's some [__] right there don't look
down
all right um so let's do a video huh
Chris saw you in Lakeland bro that show
was fun as [__] man thank you love both
of y'all love the podcast
um my question is about
caring about what other people think
about you caring about what like random
stranger okay
meeting validation and needing everyone
to like you it's like a huge thing for
me it's super annoying
um if y'all know anything about that I'd
appreciate it guys thanks I was just
talking about this with my therapist
like literally two hours ago
um
it's a sucks man dude like sorry it
sucks that no I don't but it just sucks
because you [__]
you want to feel good enough by yourself
but it's also very human to want people
to like you
so you have to find that within yourself
to be happy enough to where you don't
unhealthily go out and think people like
dude
I work out because I want to be healthy
for my kids I have to keep that in mind
okay if I work out and I start thinking
oh [__] I'm starting to look like yeah I
got to get another film crew to add to
my back because I could probably get a
production company to shoot something in
a vast [__] mountain range right we
shot Cliffhanger there yeah they could
you know and if I start thinking in that
way and then I start sneaking looks at
the gym and then women are looking at me
like God damn it looks a little beefy a
little beefier than I thought he's
actually really way more handsome in
real life I mean yeah he's good on
screen but in real life holy [__]
[__] if I start going down that road
like yeah his legs are skin but he's
skinny but he's veed out right so it
doesn't really matter you know like yeah
who cares about calves it has no
utilization for that in real life but he
could [__] carry a refrigerator
upstairs he could help me move right I
don't think you're answering the query
I'm saying that it's very unhealthy to
spiral about that you need to think
about what you're grateful for it's so
[__] hard dude it's so hard some days
I wake up and I'm just like oh dude okay
I feel good some days I wake up and I'm
just like oh it's gonna be a piece of
[__] day dude and there's nothing I can
do about it except try dude it's the
bane of my existence all I want is for
people to [__] like me and that is
sad
the worst advice you know that is so sad
just commiserating let me come at it
from a different angle
uh
this helped me with thinking about
things like my own anxiety and and
certain other things as well when I
think about them from like an actual
evolutionary standpoint it makes sense
to care of course about what people
around you think people you know people
in your community people in your society
that matters because it affects your
life it affects the life of others and
mainly it affects the way people treat
you you don't want to be exercised
exactly you don't want to be exiled from
the tribe you want to be the man however
the world for humans expanded
exponentially so so so fast that we
still have those brains so we think of
the people we don't know the same way we
think of people we do know because our
brains didn't have time to catch up with
the way we live now which is we're
connected to everybody around the entire
Globe all the time strangers are
interacting with us all the time
throughout the day doesn't matter how
involved with social media or not we are
yeah and that's crazy and the reason we
think we it's a universal thing so why
do we feel a way that is so counter to
what's good for us yeah and that's the
reason our brains have to play catch-up
and they're not good at that and if you
can think of it in a way of like okay
it's like not that you're separate from
your brain in fact you are the opposite
of separate from your brain but
sometimes your brain does things that
can't help itself and you need to be
able to recognize that and kind of put
the kabash on it early and right away
because that [__] will make you start
spiraling next thing you know you're
like completely broken up about what
[__] Sean Gonzalez in Tahiti thinks
about your shoes wow there's a showing I
was also Tahiti just like this
oh no yeah it's just you know humans
used to get men used to get [__]
their like validation from like dude
there's stuff that you can do to
minimize that compulsion of wanting
other people like dude when I when I'm
on stage I I check out I'm out of my
mind when I work out I'm out of my mind
there are ways to do this right but but
there are also like uh like we used to
get that we used to feel good about
ourselves because of
hunting because of sitting in silence
being with the family being with our
tribes and now we've got all this [__]
that is so unnatural and we're
conditioned to for likes and clicks and
you know subscriptions that we are we
are [__] basically so it makes it
worse which is kind of what Matt's
saying but yeah there's there's people
nowadays that actually the first thing
they think when they meet someone is how
many followers do they have and it's
like that's obviously we all agree that
that's terrible but that is also a very
natural progression of the thing this
guy's talking about yeah yeah yeah which
is the signifier that it's [__] and
you don't need to punish yourself for
feeling that but you do need to keep
yourself in check and in terms of how
you deal with that and behave out in the
world that's what matters it doesn't
matter what makes you feel we feel a
whole lot of things that make no sense
and are terrible we don't need to act on
them we don't need to put them out in
the world we can keep them in check
because we are civilized go be a
Buddhist monk too you could go be a boss
I take back what I said go be a Buddhist
you could live without validation right
external validation you can you can be a
you could be a Buddhist mon like I mean
I can do that you could not ever ever do
that hey you're the last person that
could do that hey
oh yeah that day one do you guys have
Tabasco sauce sorry I don't know how to
[__] how would I say it without
saying it okay fine I have to go now
seriously you wouldn't probably the
Tabasco sauce you could stay but you
can't talk oh you can't you made up that
rule well there's this vow of silence oh
yeah okay
I mean jerking a guy off so
um
yeah it's crazy also it helps to get my
orange robes I'm leaving it helps to
know that everybody feels that way
everyone does not just yeah that's right
when rappers are like I don't give a
[__] it's like yeah you do dude or even
if they don't it's expected that they do
because most people do and that's why
they say it so it's like either way
almost everyone does do though you know
no everyone yeah anyway I should be we
got to be Buddhist monks that's the way
that's the real key honestly and people
that don't care about other people think
about the opposite sociopaths exactly so
500 million dollars
sounds kind of fun all right uh next I
have you know the question and I need
some advice I stay late at my job
Wednesdays and Thursdays until six
o'clock it's a long day eight to six and
the last person to close up the store
needs to set the alarm the thing is
though there's a lot of Chatty caddies
in the office and at six o'clock they're
not ready to leave but I have to stay to
put the code in there are random days
where the Executive Vice President and
the person under her are just chatting
it's like 6 10 at night I want to go
home it's been a long day I just work
nine hours yeah 10 hours
they say they don't want to leave until
I'm there so I could set the alarm but
they have a code isn't that rude isn't
that dick why do I have to stay an extra
15 20 minutes longer sometimes when they
have a code and they could set the alarm
they're making me stay when I want to go
home what do I do what do I say to
people who have more power than me yeah
I need some advice what's his what's his
job though do you know he's not he
sounds like he's just code Setter he's
code Setter dude yeah that you gotta I
mean that's a power move what they're
doing that's not it's just the power
that's there's no even if they don't
realize it that is what it is that is an
insane thing to do unless yeah because
it is good that you said I do think
people do [__] like that without
consciously thinking you know what I'm
going to do oh death's on this guy yeah
they're just like this is what I'm
entitled to that's how they actually
think it's rarely that I think it's more
Yeah well yeah sure sure
um because they might not be bad people
they're just like oh you know right in
their subconscious they're like I'm the
boss [__] it yeah totally yeah um and
also failing marriages at home and
everything bad and they can't [__]
get a you know they can't get a Word
answers with their [__] wives or
husbands and now they they go like yo
you got to sit 10 minutes and [__]
put in the code when I walk out of the
door so now I feel good you're exactly
right and here's the problem
when it comes to approaching them about
just 15-20 minutes whatever you say the
chances of them hearing you being a
whiny brat yeah are really high now is
that fair of course not they're treating
you sub-optimally right right but I
don't know if I would advise here's what
it is is it right that they're doing
that no but it's like you have to weigh
what's going on are those 50-20 minutes
worth either good treatment at work uh
continuing to work there but keeping
your job yeah is it worth it if it is
do the thing you got to do but like you
know if it's not I think maybe just eat
it sit on it at least until it becomes
maybe more egregious because the truth
of the matter is when people do [__]
like this they just keep that's pulling
and getting longer leash next thing you
know you'll be there at seven and then
you can say hey why you guys keeping me
a whole hour after work I don't want to
be here yeah and I'm not getting paid
for this then you're in the right
without question but the 15 minutes are
gonna be like Oh I'm sorry like it's so
weird you know well hopefully he gets
paid for the uh I think he's implying
that he doesn't see that well then he
should then he should say yo you guys
sometimes keep me 6 15. I I you know I
should get paid for that hour yes yes do
that that's the way to go because it's
it's actually probably it's probably not
legally true yeah I mean we're presuming
that that's the case yeah it sounds like
that's the case and if it is though
definitely that is the place to live and
if you're getting paid for that extra
hour already
you're [__] right right I don't do
that a lot but sometimes I gotta pull
out the toucan boys but what I don't
know you're [__] you don't have ground
to stay
we're working on but too bad you're
[__] you're getting paid from six to
seven okay along with the rest of the
day when you do the toucan voice I think
you should have a prepared like three or
four words you're gonna say right
because when you go on like that it's
the worst it's like the worst experience
sentences it's the worst experience
there you go right because well not
because no because of all right nope
because maybe you've been working too
long yeah yeah okay uh yeah dude make it
about the money
just go up to your boss and say listen
do it in the two count boys listen
Benjamins
need more
as if you need more Benjamins oh
my God the boss would be like sorry what
can I talk to you for a second
need more Benjamins
[Laughter]
what was the word that you said
Benjamins but I'm saying I need more
Benjamins okay what's the part before
need more need more need more Benjamins
like I need to get paid it'd be the
worst way I need to get paid you know
what it's 6 30 we should all get home
I'll see you tomorrow Jonathan
we sure got him this time I'm back home
all right all right well
oh hey Matt hey Chris my name is Randy
never seen something I live in Tacoma
Washington I also live full time in my
truck I work Monday through Friday I get
Saturday and Sunday off I also live in
my truck Saturday and Sunday I don't
have a house I don't have an apartment
and I don't have any roommate
Arrangement a living situation my
question is how would I approach getting
into a relationship with a woman how
would I confront her about my living
situation
any tips are much appreciated thank you
bye I mean his hygiene looks so good
that's crazy you don't think of somebody
who lives in their car like that
I don't know where to start do you
you gotta have killer swag dude well the
thing is
in my truck actually more and more I was
actually reading about this more and
more people are
choosing to do what this guy does yeah
where like it's actually not that they
can't afford to get an apartment or rent
a house whatever it doesn't matter it's
that they're like I Wanna Be I have this
really nice vehicle that I already own
or can own that is going to be just as
comfortable if not more to me and it's a
mobile and it's this and it's that and
he lives in Washington not downtown L.A
right so I mean I don't think
I mean the thing is always going to be
the way you are about it yeah so if
you're just like
whenever it comes up you you talk about
it because and you talk about how much
you like it or yeah not from like a
point of defensiveness but like well no
matter what it'll sound effective if you
enjoy that lifestyle you want to if it
comes up you just talk about it and then
and then be like and if don't worry if I
ever move into your house I'll just
sleep in the driveway in my truck I'll
just drive the truck inside your house
yeah that's how yeah I'm in the living
room I mean honestly you just here's
what you do hey I um I live in my truck
and she says you live in your truck and
you say you don't yeah that could work
but it's actually the [__] dude it's the
[__] but you're taking a oh that's him
talking yeah right I mean that is bad
yeah that is a bad idea I would never
live in a house no matter what
saying so much about the potential
future you know
um yeah that's a tough thing you got to
just own it I mean sometimes there's no
advice it's like you gotta obviously you
gotta meet the right person dude you got
to meet the right person you gotta
there's chicks that live in their truck
I think moreover there's people out
there that don't care if you live in
your truck right now trying to think if
I but like they would care if you were
like it was time to move in together and
he was like no I live in my truck what
are you talking about that would be a
problem okay so if you met a woman and
you had a house and you and she had she
was like I live in my truck but she was
dope what would you do move in you have
her move in yeah I mean I'd ask you want
to move in yeah you're living at your
truck that wouldn't be a red flag to you
because it would kind of be a little bit
of a red flag
look and my sense from this guy is that
he actually has his stuff together I
could be wrong if at first I'd be like
that's so weird but then if she showed
me the truck and I was like oh wait this
is like I get it then I wouldn't be but
I think yes like you you know you don't
as a general rule it's a red flag yeah
yeah but right right yeah it's something
to like inspect for sure because if they
live in their car there's not nothing
furnished inside it's just a car inside
and like there's clothes everywhere then
it's like huge red flag right you know
what I mean right
um maybe this is different cars like
this car is my closet this one over here
is the living room
that's where the magic happens all he
owns in terms of uh properties a
driveway yeah
um that's pretty wild I wonder what
that's like I bet that that makes in a
way it's freeing yeah but that's what I
mean that's I think that's right people
do it yeah but uh yeah I think I think
to present it whenever it comes up as
something that you believe in and are
confident in without sounding
make sure you don't sound defensive yeah
exactly but he also he has a job he does
he works every day on the weekdays yeah
so right well that's why we're not
saying first thing move out of your car
yeah yeah yeah he's choosing to live in
his car yeah
um yeah all right cool yeah yeah owner
ownership is the is the thing yeah and
not just of the car yeah all right
hi Matt hi Chris I'm a long time
listener of both congrats and Lifeline
my question for you guys mostly for
Chris though because he's been so open
about a struggle with OCD which thank
you because it helped me to let my
ex-boyfriend know that that's what he
was dealing with and he's getting
treatment now but oh wow my question is
how do you make somebody with OCD feel
understood because I know that it's a
very misunderstood diagnosis to have and
it's very isolating as well
um it's important to me because my ex
has it we broke up because of his OCD
who's having a relationship OCD really
bad and one of my best friends
um Samantha also has it so
um I guess how how do I make them feel
understood how do I support them
um how do you and Kristen do it how do
you maintain a relationship when one of
you has really bad OCD what do you guys
do on the hard days
um any guidance that you can offer would
be really appreciated
um
yeah so well
it's weird OCD is a weird thing because
it presents itself in such different
ways with different people
um
some days are really really really hard
for me
and I try to let Kristen know or people
I'm with no if I trust them
um for me it's about minimizing my
anxiety but it sucks because I like to
be quiet and have people be uh not
bothering me it's sometimes impossible I
mean now we have two kids and [__] so
it's like you know she may need me and
it's really tough
um it's really hard to not be short
and not it's hard for me to not get too
frustrated
um but I try to let her know when I have
extreme uh I'm having a bad day uh it
sucks that you guys broke up over it uh
I wonder what she meant he's having
relationship OCD like what you know what
you remember that
well I I just took it as they tried to
um
it's just been affecting the
relationship I mean she specifically
said no he's suffering from relationship
I'll say that I don't know what that is
right perfectly but
um maybe he I'm sure it causes it to
flare up when he's in a relationship
which is not which is normal because
it's stressful he's probably you know
dealing with some sort of whatever
happened to him when he was a kid in his
childhood and and now it's activated
because he's with somebody else
intimately and that can be a struggle
it's definitely it was a struggle for me
uh whenever I got into a relationship
when like letting the partner know about
OCD it got
um it got [__] up it got [__] up um
and uh it's hard but but uh I think that
um
she's asking for advice on how to help
him but she's the ex right
she yeah but she's still friends with
him and she has another friend who
suffers from it I think look
one way to understand OCD in so far as I
do as someone who doesn't have OCD but
does have anxiety is that the way I had
it explained to me was by my therapist
was
OCD and anxiety or or two branches from
the same tree it's actually the same
part of the brain it's just the Alchemy
of it that none of us understand it is
such that it manifests in ways that are
OCD in some people and in anxiety in
other people and so if you think about
it on on that spectrum of anxiety that
anxiety depression spectrum of like
you know people who are depressed people
are anxious they're not choosing to be
anxious yeah but also to me
I treat people with it is how I try to
control my anxiety is through my OCD
which is I have to let that go but it's
nearly impossible it's like having
Tourette Syndrome or something like that
like it's so hard to not do the rituals
and not under and not feel that anxiety
it feels so uncomfortable so I have to
like I think honestly exposure therapy
is good
um I did some of that
um I took a little bit of I take a
little bit of medication for my OCD not
a little bit I mean I take some
um I've tried different medications so
that's good I think the best combo is
medication through and behavioral
therapy that can do uh really good it
did it did well for me it's [__] so
hard man but what she's asking is what
would how should people be about
yourself well I think like I said it's
different for everybody but for me I
think that it's best to just not like
when I'm going through one of my things
I just gotta sit down if people talk to
me it's worse if people try to help it's
worse like they don't know what you're
you're never going to know what he's
going through in his head so it's kind
of a solo battle which kind of sucks too
because you feel like you're not
connected with them because they're not
sharing it with you but maybe during a
down time of it they can share it to you
like during during my parts where I'm
not as just I've told Kristen about it
um and we joke about it too that helps
um I used to not even be able to joke
about it but
um yeah it's just uh I think that let
them take the lead and and and it can be
very frustrating if it's too frustrating
then you know I guess you can't be with
that person
um because it's it's you know you got to
have boundaries yourself yeah I mean I
always expected when my either
girlfriends or uh you know I've been
married not this is my second marriage I
always expected when I started dating
somebody when they found out about my
OCD it was gonna be too much about them
this is going to be too much for them
and they were gonna leave me but man I
don't know women are amazing they
[__] care you know and they wanna
they wanna you know they're very loving
or you know they can be and so that
never happened but I don't know
it's it's a really [__] hard thing to
get through especially for also a
partner because you don't know what the
[__] going on in their heads so yeah
let them know it's fine
let them know it's fine yeah if you
think it's fine let them know it's fine
it's okay and you got to deal with your
[__] and and and and I'll be here which
I guess you guys broke up I don't know
if you broke up with you you broke up
with him but yeah and for your friend
just let them let your friend know it's
okay
especially chicks they love talking
about it so good what's that remember
the uh oh no so mine it was a Snapple
thing yeah
okay
what's up man Chris loving the show dude
the earrings really appreciated our 101
session super super cool
my question today is
you know I've become a sort of coffee
pickles espresso Aficionado type guy
that's a pickle jar bragging
but it's like everywhere
like that I know how to make it right
you know yeah because I'm starting to
make this stuff at my house I got a
whole machine for it and stuff and now
when I go to coffee shops I know when
they're making it wrong yeah they're not
grinding black coffee freshly and
pouring it out making another shot
they're using that same old coffee stale
ground is this crazy
if I get four shots they're running the
same
what I want I know they're doing it
wrong they
threw up and I'm like huh what is this
right
do I say something or do I say
thanks
I hated it poison poison that's the
place help me
you're grinding my beans wrong that's
all I can say you're running it through
when you should make four extra shots
[Laughter]
oh come on now it's important I think
that let it go man
Let It Go yeah uh or start at the top of
it look
I know
I know what I know what this looks like
uh what what I need hey I know what this
looks like dangly yeah yeah I know what
this looks like what I need
is it to be done like this
make a song out of it get on the counter
start walking around
uh
uh he made it wrong like Bob grinding my
beans are wrong
they're [__] it up I asked for a quad
shot espresso not four separation hot
wow you use the same [__] thing to
make all the four shots
God damn it
ah come on you're gonna arrest them his
friends ah cappers
um why
are you keep going
up grinding same shots it's the same
shot nose grease so well
what the [__] dude
um
you you can't get mad at someone for
making it the way that they make it with
the paper straws all right tell them to
make it how you want it if you think
they're gonna [__] it up let them know
ahead of time be an annoying customer up
front yeah don't make them do it twice
or go home and make it yourself if you
know they're gonna [__] it up you such a
huge ass you're just like okay I'm gonna
order I bet they're not gonna get it
right in your head in your head and then
you watch them the whole time like a
[__] Eagle they make the mistake
because you knew that they would because
that's how they do it at this coffee
shop then they finally bring it to you
and you say um
do it at the beginning hey I want to I
want the espresso in a cup ice you're
gonna [__] it up huh right you're gonna
[__] it up you're gonna run it through
the beans like that twice four times no
you're not
I want a separate
um yeah dude make it yourself if you
unless you enjoy see for me I go to a
place that sometimes has worse coffee
than what I would make but I enjoy going
to actually get the coffee I enjoy
walking in getting it having them call
my name it's a whole ritual I like to
talk about OCD like the worst [__]
though I'm just thinking about I'm just
steaming about this while you're talking
because you're talking about it like you
like the ritual of going to some good
place to get a good cup of coffee you
like going to the shittiest [__]
places I go to any place I like the
actual yeah except when you get the
coffee at the good place you say ah what
the [__] is this sometimes yeah and
that's a wrong way to be wow you like
bad [__] that's not true necessarily
Jones on third has good coffee Alf
Alfred's has bad coffee dude no and then
sometimes you think a place has [__]
good coffee [__] Alfred and sometimes
you think a place has bad coffee like I
went to where did I go and I kept going
and I kept and the four shots were awful
and then one day I was like dude just
give me the I have the Cobra I got it
Cobra's fantastic so now I'm just gonna
get the Cobra there sometimes you got to
figure out what they got that's just
there the thing about it try something
else why I'm so triggered is because
it's not just coffee for you yeah like
that about everything right you're like
the shitty version no yes I like the
good stuff because I'm No Frills I'm
Mister No Frills hey Mr nope wait was it
Mr Big Stuff who do you think you are ah
Mr No Frills that's who I am doing I get
it yeah yeah you didn't need to so the
big so big so so Mr Big Stuff so yeah I
um yeah go order something else there
try something else try different things
there's some coffee shops some coffee
shops excel in other drinks that you
wouldn't necessarily get I don't like to
get cold brew too much but sometimes
when I'm out of place I get the cold
brew because I know the espresso [__]
if you want it the way a specific way
tell them true just say it that is true
when you go to especially when you go to
these [__] chains of Starbucks yeah
do it like this I don't want to share I
want two pumps to the thing you're a
[__] [__] anyway it's just be like
you're way less of an [__] to do it
then than after dude that you're even
asking if you should say it after is
mind-boggling to me obviously say it up
front yeah this guy doesn't know what's
going on this guy's getting it wrong
dude you're doing you're giving the
earring a bad name change or take the
earring out he has a side necktie and an
earring okay well you did you notice
that you're giving us a bad name man did
you notice that get with the program
yeah dude hopefully you don't have a big
dick you give us all a bad name we have
that too right it's crazy okay Anthony's
penis would fit in the bag though that
meant microscopic it's in there
you want to have sex hold on one second
hahaha
oh
you saw cute dog what time what time I'm
just weighing whether to tell the story
yeah yeah you did I won't mention any
names but I'll tell the story uh A
girlfriend of mine was telling me a
story that she had sex with a guy who
his he who
a
was as big as a thimble okay and I was
like it wasn't me and I was like well
what are you like what do you mean like
how big was it really yep and she said
it was like a thimble man it was a
thimble wow I thought of a thimble whoa
peeking out the hair and I was like it's
one thing I was like but but that's a
joke you're telling a joke and I get it
and I think it's funny but what size was
the penis oh yeah and it just went on
and on I just couldn't
look we're talking and I said okay show
me the size you mean that yeah like this
yep yep I said it's a [__] basically I
mean this is it that is that is a dick
this is how you have this is how you
give oral sex to that guy oh man no this
is not oh gross dude nose [__] that's
not oral yeah well it's facial Hazel
nasal sex nasal [__] ill you ever nasal
sex ever nasal [__]
um this is how you jerk them off
cleaning windows
oh man Windex
would hurt so don't hurt so bad
Nicholas Cage
um I personally think that uh I yeah
that guy wasn't me I have a huge penis
okay I personally think that is
a huge bummer that that's true do you
know what I mean have a small penis
infection no not a small penis that what
uh that's a symbol thumbnail thimble
thimble dude I mean it sounds like we're
saying symbol with a list
it was a thimble and really what was it
it was like a circular wide
laughs
uh yeah she just had a lisp that's true
yeah uh no but do you know what I mean
about the world it's so disillusioning
to know that there are men out there
with that size of penis it's like my
heart breaks yeah not me dude get good
at like other stuff it doesn't really
matter if you have a small penis now I
will tell you this it matters for your
own man stop saying small P that's not
what a small penis is that is the
biggest the size of my pee it's called a
micropenis it is yeah but I don't know
because I looked it up but that's not a
small penis right I know it's like
saying small people or in short people
those are not the same things okay so so
micro penis is the medical term of it
and I don't have one I've seen
the images on the internet about it not
in real life because I'm not getting
exactly wrong with that yeah so you can
do that have you actually seen pictures
I'm asking micro penis Google micropenis
I would get upset dude like I said it is
it is disheartening to me I get sad I
gotta take a minute really yeah dude
yeah I don't I go like this yeah because
you're less caring and less than I'm not
I'm an empath you're the opposite of an
Empire no I'm an empath no all right
well I am an empath but I covered it up
we do more wow no I feel like I feel
like honestly I like this penis talk but
okay if you have a like one of those
pasta shell penises right where it's
just the shell you know what I'm talking
about do you know I know the pasta but I
don't know well it did because it looks
like a little like a little curved like
like one of those Mario Brothers uh
turtle shells like that's what your
penis looks like oh that's what it looks
okay all not green okay red but right no
they're green yeah but um yep and green
if you had an STD and so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so um and you take your
penis out he goes
um and then you put it in your vagina
goes
running a bird
thank you
that's how you have sex if you have a
little uh penis uh the size
no oh he's doing it again I love I love
that he's doing it again
um
so anyway dude
um I think that micropenis is a real
thing and and that's uh it affects your
whole life it it gets in your head I
don't have a big penis that's all you're
thinking about in real life that's all
you're thinking about it's like honestly
having HIV like you can't stop thinking
about it you're just doing other things
too relax though because one is gonna
literally kill you and the other one
isn't but I know but I'm saying like the
movie what it is is it's an existential
Health yeah exactly you're living same
because all you're thinking about is HIV
why would I bother getting into this
relationship or that relationship when
they're going to see this little symbol
anyway that that is what breaks my heart
about it because you'll be a movie
theater
you'll be at a movie theater and they'll
be like would you want butter in your
popcorn and in your head before you
actually be like doesn't matter I have a
really [__] micropenis uh yeah I have
butter like that's how your whole life
would be I don't think it extends to
movie theater I do uh I do I personally
do like Fast X is cool I have a small
penis but look at Vin Diesel it it is
all about family oh God I have a [__]
conch shell for a penis but whoa
[Laughter]
oh man see even though I'm laughing I'm
not well totally out after the pain
there's laugh at the pain I'm not
totally happy about it yeah all right
well should we do one yeah yeah I'm hot
here we go hey guys uh
love you guys so my question is
I'm seeing two females knew something
was up with this guy
one
one someone who
who likes to do the horizontal slam
Mambo uh
uh multiple times a week and it's great
but we don't connect much on a
personal level
whereas the other one we connect great
on a personal level have very good
conversations but
the horizontal slamming is limited to
once a week or once every couple weeks
so
just in your opinion what should I do
um
and in the past I went with the one that
loved to do the slamming and she cheated
on me so oh whoa yeah any advice would
be great thanks brother
we first of all we've had this before
yeah pause it it's like an age-old like
was it the same exact guy no because he
did a video of it
the other guy had a video it was a
different guy really this is an age-old
thing if you're a player player this is
how it goes dude sounds like a young guy
you know he's a player his own question
dude I know what is he
very well put is it very well thought
out and then the very Andy answers his
own question and then pretends like he
did yeah is he possibly a dumb [__] I
mean he's a complete dumb [__] yeah you
go with the one the guy wants to but he
loves the sex you go with the one that's
not gonna
cheat on you well you don't know she's
gonna cheat on him you can't just use
your past experiences to color your your
future experiences like that wait I'm
sorry isn't he saying it's the same two
women and it's the one oh oh he did not
necessarily say that it could be true
but he said in the past I've done this
situation and you know oh he didn't mean
no he didn't no he didn't oh no okay
well then anyways if he does he's a
[__] idiot
I think that it's true what Chris is
alluding to which is that just because
someone likes to have a lot of sex
doesn't mean that they're gonna go do it
it doesn't mean they're gonna back with
other people whoops oops Yeah 100 so
then oops to what you said right but
he's a player player and he's not that's
not indicative of someone who cheats it
just isn't
um in fact it's just as likely that the
person that refuses to have sex with you
a lot is cheating and like doesn't want
to actually have sex with two people
anyway so it's like don't take that as a
sign of
what is in front of you right now I
would say and you kind of also answered
this that like
beyond the the if you just want to date
around and it's like casual do whichever
one you want in fact keep seeing both as
long as you're not lying about it but
like if you're looking for an actual
relationship I can tell you one
gazillion out of one gazillion times if
the thing you're seeking is an actual
relationship the one that you get along
with best is going to be the one that
has the best chance to succeed long term
because that sex that desire to [__]
like rabbits if it doesn't go away it
diminishes greatly over time and what's
left is just that other person you
better [__] like that person
otherwise
you're going to be cheating and she's
going to be cheating also and it's a
whole waste of time good also
um
I have this thing where like
he's asking this question they're both
not right it doesn't matter you know
when you know dude he sounds young right
um like in his 20s I think he sounds
like he's at least 30. okay well I mean
it depends on where you are that could
still be young in L.A if it is but
you know uh if you're wanting to settle
down they're both wrong
because you just know it's true right
you know if you're wanting a casual
relationship that it doesn't matter what
you're doing as long as you're being
you're not lying to them yeah right yeah
so both of those things matter if you
are the kind of guy that you're like I
should be in a relay it's no should or
shouldn't you do what you want to do
just don't lie to them about it like I
used to do and
um and be upfront and then and then but
you don't want to be with either of them
is that just period because you can find
the best of both worlds let me make sure
I understand why you're saying that
you're saying only because he would know
or because like neither one of them is
jumping across and saying hey it's not
clear that one of them is for him so
you're saying neither one is which one
is it I don't understand the difference
of what you're saying the difference is
of what I'm saying is like
you're talking about here it's either a
feeling or it's an actual assessment of
the two people which one are you saying
feelings okay yeah he would know you
would know you wouldn't be who should I
be with
you're not you're not are you in love
with both of them which I guess could
happen if you are then it's a little bit
more complicated but it feels like
you're not that's that's really pretty
rare I mean in my life between love true
love oh yeah it's pretty rare so I'm not
saying drop them both but be honest if
they ask you you know yeah I think is it
sounded like maybe he what they did know
like it's still I'm reading into this
admittedly but it sounds like he was
saying
a thing that seems out in the open but
then again he didn't own voice only they
probably have no idea and I bet he has
lied about it so step one stop lying and
in that stopping lying you should at the
very least decide which one of those two
you are most interested in that being
said they might not be so interested in
you after they learn that you're also
dating someone else while you're dating
them so look in the [__] mirror okay
I guess that's good man
should that be it yeah I don't know I
don't think yeah that's the last one all
right cool well then that's good man I
feel like uh we did a lot of really good
advices
yeah yeah we did good is it really hot
in here right now oh it's [__]
extremely hot it's interesting I always
feel hot and I don't right now isn't
that weird the inside of your body is a
certain thing even though the outside is
always constant yeah right I'm always
always always too hot though and now I'm
not I'm wondering why sometimes 75
degrees is too hot sometimes it's not
and it depends on you what a philosopher
I'm a philosopher and I'll also be in
Knoxville Charlotte
Knoxville Charlotte Cleveland uh
Nashville Montreal uh Vegas
chrysalia.com uh and then you can go to
uh uh the different websites which
Anthony doesn't have up so that's cool
so he's fired
um and oh patreon.com there's another
episode of Lifeline luxury patreon.com
Lifeline luxury uh and uh if you have a
question click the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com
or leave us a message on the hotline
213-973-8095 or if you want a one-on-one
session with me go to mattelia.com to
book that and of course get the
beautiful new Lifeline merch at
lifelinemerch.com it's gone fast
it's going going going going going
almost gone you're going to want to get
it now I'm Chris Berman thank you
hello hello hello hello
[Music]